we're the center of Janine refugee camp
it's about half a kilometer Square in
size but 18 000 people live here it's
very very cramped and this is where most
of the heavy fighting took place uh
there's cars that probably have been hit
by air strikes
a lot of the buildings have got bullet
holes on the walls and many of the
streets are like this one they've been
dug up by the Israeli bulldozers as they
came in at the start of the operation to
try and clear roadside bombs but it also
cut off the electricity so they've been
working to restore the electricity today
a lot of cleaning up going on the
funerals have taken place within the
last hour or so for those who were
killed during the Israeli operation the
Israelis it's been about 48 Hours here
they left in the early hours of
Wednesday morning
it's not the first time that they've
carried out a military operation in
Janine and it won't be the last